[Music]
welcome to worlds of speculative fiction
session 39 I believe which is focused on
Carl Edward Wagner short-lived fantasy
sci-fi horror author also very important
for editing he really spent a lot of his
time editing he had a quite interesting
life it was a component it was indeed
rather short unfortunately I was just
reflecting on the fact that I am now
older than this guy got to be I turned
49 this year and he died at 48 years old
you know he probably had some control
over that if he hadn't drank so much he
he would have lived longer but we'll
talk about what that was the case and so
in this this series we always talked
about some world building stuff and the
biography of the person and then I've
usually got some philosophical themes
picked out usually you all have some
philosophical themes that you want to
discuss with this but I thought I would
actually begin with a little bit of
reminiscence because one of the reasons
I picked Carl Edward Wagner is he was a
favorite of mine since I was 9 and I
there was this this store out in
Delafield
called the farm while I was in this
place called the barn which was a
converted barn and we'd get to go out
there and they had like you know penny
candy store and the things like that and
there was a bookstore up on the very top
and it didn't last long so I don't think
they were very good at selling books but
they had death angels shadow and
you know I looked at the the cover of it
and you know death angel shadow that
sounds pretty cool and it showed this
giant werewolf
you know attacking this guy who was get
you know the warrior you can't see his
face he's got a sword thrust out I
thought that sounds pretty good so I
bought it and then we almost immediately
afterwards went on this this river trip
we had a boat at the time and along with
a couple other families we went out to
the cross and we for a week we went up
and down the Mississippi camping out on
sand dunes and so I brought that that
book and a few others with me and I just
read it and read it and read it and I
think part of the the reason why I read
it so assiduously was unlike other
fantasy stuff that I'd read until death
there's a lot of sex in Carl Edwards
stuff you know well yeah and I was
fascinated with this this hero cane and
then you know just kind of I'd read it
and and when I found other Carl Edward
Wagner stuff I read those and I I liked
him I never was able to find most of his
work in like the you know the at that
time I was going to the Waukesha library
I don't think they carried that sort of
thing at that time no well now I think a
lot of his stuff is out of print
except for you can get a very very nice
and also expensive edition of the three
you know three novel gods and darkness
this is Marquette's copy I'll actually
pass this around it's got the bug man
it's also it's got it's a limited
edition this edition that says has been
limited to 150 copies all of which have
been signed by the but the artist Kevin
Kelly and but I I'm you know when I was
living in New York I didn't have too
much trouble finding his his stuff most
of it now I had to get it the rest of it
all in kindle where it's a
so yeah he's been somebody I've wanted
to talk about for for quite a while and
so revisiting the Cain stories was a lot
of fun he does the same thing that we
talked about during which is in each of
his novels there's sort of an expository
page or so where he tells you the the
back story of Cain just like Derleth
does with like the whole Cthulhu Mythos
thing but it's not as long or as wordy
and he's a better writer than than
during what was I think so that that
that's that let's talk a little bit
about the guy himself and his his life
his timeline sometimes you know these
timelines that I have for you are like
two pages long this this one not quite
so long he didn't he didn't write too
many books he read a lot of short
stories but he didn't write that many
books and he he didn't live that that
long and it's actually hard to find
information about some of the key
moments of his life like we know for
example when he got separated and
divorced from his wife Barbara can't
find out when they got married I did a
lot of scouring you know the internet
and you just can't find it it's
complicated by the fact that there's
also another Carl Edward Wagner who
lived and died earlier so you get a
little bit of signal noise you could say
but so he's born in Knoxville Tennessee
his his parents actually went to UWM
interestingly enough and he had a you
know I wouldn't say an unremarkable
childhood because he was already you
know reading pulps and doing some a lot
of little writing things of his own he
talks about that and one of the things
I've given me too as a set of passages
so in an interview with Bradley sinner
he says my first stories were published
in grammar school in high school
newspapers lost now I hope as a high
school software I wrote some of the
worst post lash Lovecraft pass teachers
ever attempted but got good grades from
my English teacher
and now this is really interesting I
began writing bloodstone which is a cane
novel at this time in 1960 and captain a
for the prologue at this time I was
submitting very short stories to the
existing markets with success in 61 I
completed the first cane story the
treasure of lenore test which well not
bad for a 16 year old Punk did not crash
fantasy and sci-fi this was completely
rewritten later after 10 years of this I
family made my first sale a Caine novel
to Powell publications I'm gonna put off
that for a little bit because there's a
whole funny story involved in that so he
graduates and he enrolls at Kenyon
College in Ohio so he's moving up north
and he studies history and he was asked
later on you know did studying history
help you writing novels and say yeah of
course it said you know gave me a way to
understand narratives and and how to
tell stories and and a lot of good
background information so he goes to
Kenyon and while he's doing that he's
he's still continuing writing as well
and then he go he goes to Chapel Hill
Inn in North Carolina and he decides he
wants to go to medical school but he's
going to medical school to become a
psychiatrist he's picked up an interest
in the human mind and you know of course
in order to become a psychiatrist you
have to be an MD so he's going there for
that and he's got a sort of well I won't
even call it a love hate relationship
with psychiatry it's more of a hate hate
relationship eventually because um he so
he goes to medical school and and he's
going at a time when according to him
the the view was if you were really
serious about your medical profession
you should have no time for anything
else
and it was a time of you know student
activism so he was he was interested in
what was going on and say Vietnam
protests or things along those lines and
he was told if you do any of that sort
of stuff were you're done here
you're you don't have the time to screw
around with having a life outside of
medical school and it was very sort of
you know old school top down almost like
hazing going on right and he didn't like
that he was always kind of a rebel sort
I would say and so while he's there in
in medical school he publishes his first
book and so I'll just read you some of
his stuff he says I finally made my
first sale a Caine novel to Powell
publications in 1969 I'd written the
novel during my senior year at Kenyon it
was bounced everywhere then browsing the
newsstand I spotted a really tacky
sword-and-sorcery novel from Powell or
something like that reasoning that any
publisher would publish something like
that putrid published something that
putrid would publish me he says this is
a mature reasoning and does not hold up
in practice
I sent them they bought it the book came
out in February 1970 I got my copy while
on pediatrics my classmates asked if it
were a porno as I read in the interns
loud as they read it the interns lounge
that night and it had been cut by about
a third they edited it without his
permission took out a whole bunch of the
important stuff and then he says Kane
had been changed into a black to match
the cover of a black swordsman with a
banana stuffed into this orange
jockstrap and the typos and that but it
but he you know he also says well was it
first novel and it got my foot in the
door because now once you're established
as a writer even if it's like just total
crap you are a writer so you can go
around and say you know nobody's
actually gonna read your book say I'm a
published writer I'm a published author
you know how about you consider my next
book and so he says it opened up doors
for him but it but he was very
disappointed with with the addition and
he'll he later revised it into
to another version now he does get a
deal for me he also had he drops out of
medical school to write bloodstone and
he's got death angels shadow which is
three novellas he gets that sold to a
publishing press to paperback library
and then he's got bloodstone and that
seems like it's going to get sold and
then the the editor calls him up and
says I got really really bad news for
you we may not even be able to publish
Death Angel shadow because we've been
bought out by buy paperback live bird
we've been brought up by Warner and
they're not interested in this swords
and sorcery stuff anymore
they're they think it's a bad market
we're returning the manuscript of
bloodstone to you and we'll we'll see
what happens with death angel shadow so
he's sort of like you know in suspense
and he decides to go back to medical
school but before he does that he founds
a publishing house Carcosa house with
with two of his buddies David Drake and
Jim gross and the idea behind that he's
visited within another little passage
yeah he says after I dropped out of
medical school for a few years I wanted
to start my own small press Robert
Chambers has probably been the most
profound influence on my work and I
liked the idea of using his mythical
city of Carcosa as my California I
obtained permission to revive the kala
foam from the four partners in the
original LA based Carcosa press August
Derleth had just died and it appeared
that Arkham House was dead as well so I
arranged to publish an orphan book by my
friend Manley Wade Wellman entitled
worse things waiting which Arkham had
been holding on the backburner for
twenty years after Wellman and Derleth
quarrel and then you know so the idea
here they never actually did publish
many blocks but the idea here was
Derleth who we talked about last session
he had filled a really important need by
creating Arkham House right
that made it possible for not just
Lovecraft but other authors to to have
their work come back out that otherwise
would have been just lost sort of like
if you think about our film industry
there's so much old film that's just
gone you know because preserving it
takes a lot it wasn't made to really
last people didn't keep track of things
so it you know if Daryl if hadn't come
around and decided to make sure
Lovecraft stuff woulda got published I
don't know that a lot of it would have
survived so I think you know Wagner song
himself is sort of a successor to to
Derleth in that sense and and Wagner
really is a he's a science fiction and
fantasy author but he really is a horror
author more than anything else so that
was an important thing and then he goes
back to medical school and he graduates
and begins his psychiatric residency I
actually found a funny news clipping
online of you know showing him with his
you know scruffy beard and you know
so-and-so the you know Wagner new
resident and this psych hey the
psychiatric thing and he hated it he
said that that he wasn't that he felt
like psychiatry was all bunk or
something like that but what he what he
really hated was that at that time there
were there were lots of institutions
open right and there was there was a
good bit of money for the psychiatric
industry they were using
electroconvulsive therapy pretty heavily
back then and so he saw it getting
prescribed for all sorts of things that
it probably would have not been
indicated for now now that it's it's
used effectively with some people but
back then it was getting used pretty
pretty indiscriminately and the
hospitals were making a lot
money on it and so he really didn't like
that and he says I'm not I'm done with
that you know I'm getting out of here
I can also you know write and do that
sort of thing and by that time he starts
to become you know through the canes
stories he starts to become you know an
established author invited to cons
people know him they buy him drinks
you know I should mention that really
since high school lot he's a drinker
because that's gonna play a role in his
death later on he's a you know he's you
know he's really enjoying himself he
also did a lot of quite a few drugs too
in the 70s
not so much later on but you know he
talks quite openly about that he's
publishing more and more stuff more cane
stuff dark crusade comes out he wins a
British Fantasy Award later he'll win a
World Fantasy Award
another British Fantasy Award so he's
going to all these conventions he also
in 1980 takes it on the job that's a big
job of editing the year's best horror
stories that's a yearly anthology that
he edits I think all the way through all
the way to his death and so that's you
know when you're when you're doing
editing work as opposed to writing it's
you know how to put it your your says
same thing with like publishing having a
press you're contributing to the world
of letters in a way that makes things
possible editing work is pretty
thankless from from my experience of
doing academic editing work and editing
stoicism today I see you nodding over
there you do it for a living so
we put together books yeah yeah nobody
nobody comes up to you and says like oh
my god you're the editor of
such-and-such right whereas you're not
there you know but it is it is an awful
lot of work so you know it was Ellery
Queen a real person or not because that
would be somebody who's kind of famous
as a editor right so in any case that
that's what that's what he's doing and
you can see the books you know sort of
rolling out it's not a huge production I
didn't put the short stories on there
like I said but and then I put the
separation and divorce from his wife
Barbara so that's a really sad story and
and it's recounted in some of the other
people online who've written about Carl
Edward Wagner he had this wife and
apparently they were they were quite you
know quite the power couple for for a
while she was much more attractive than
he was he was you know this is this red
haired biker looking guy he wore you
know like black leather a lot of the
time and he was kind of kind of you know
big and portly I guess and so they'd go
to all the conventions and have fun with
all the people and go to all the parties
and stuff like that and then things
started breaking down between them and
when they did divorce she kept going to
all the conventions that he was going to
because she was a sci-fi fan as well and
she would bring you know her newest
usually you know kind of boyish it was
kind of guys that she was meeting out in
California and apparently is what one of
the people says you know he'd walk into
the room and his effect would just like
drop you know and that he'd go drink
some more and he started drinking more
and more heavily withdrawing into
himself and
you know in in 1994 so this isn't that
launched seven years after that he ends
up dying of heart and liver failure no
doubt exacerbated by his alcoholism he
was still you know writing still editing
and some of his stuff gets published
later on yeah marriage oh good how do
you find it I just it's a Wikipedia it
know the date of his marriage 1974 I
must have like read through it like a
dozen times they listed his spouse and
bracketed okay 1974 to 1986 okay there
we go
she was his spouse yeah so 74 must have
been the wedding date you get different
dates though some people say that his
divorce was in 89 they make all the
separation they might campuses yeah yeah
okay yeah it took a while to get
divorced back then didn't it
I think I don't know you know I don't
know you know what North Carolina was
like maybe it was one of those states
three after like demonstrates something
is going on you know most places have
no-fault divorce now but yeah the
seventies you had a lot of places here
catch somebody and yeah you know North
is totally off topic North Carolina
actually has a law there's a charge
called estrangement of affection if
somebody cheats them so many cheats on
their spouse the spouse can effectively
sue the person who was who the person
cheated with for a strange man affection
yeah when and I think there's monetary
damages for that I I found that out when
I was living in North Carolina somebody
that told me that I was like what how
does that work you know because we don't
have anything like that up here you know
but you know that that's the way it is
so that that's his life and and you know
he I do um read another passage - he
talks about where Cain comes from and he
said Cain grew out of my childhood
fascination for the villain he's not a
sword and sorcery hero he's a gothic
hero or villain from the tradition of
gothic novels of the 18th and 19th
centuries what I wanted to do is create
this mysterious a moral character far
more intelligent and far more physically
powerful than his adversaries before
Cain villains were either twisted
geniuses or hulking Wolf's with King and
I wanted a character could master any
situation intellectually or rip heads
off if push came to shove through man
shoe with muscles Cain is closer to the
Terminator than Conan though neither
comparison is really valid I suppose the
best description is to consider keen a
genetically engineered organic cyborg
created via magic and alien science
we'll talk about what do you mean by
that
you bet but you'll find out more later
my conception of Cain has not changed
over solid 35 years I've always this is
really interesting considered the series
as horror or gothic as opposed to sword
and sorcery when Powell published
darkness weaves you know in its porn you
know print I described the series as
gothic fantasy and I also labeled it in
their addition later when working with
Gary Hoffmann stand on his
groundbreaking small press magazine I
described the King stories as dark
fantasy that's and that's kind of a cool
term - he liked that
used it and yes I coined the term dark
fantasy I'm not sure if you really did
coin the term that's probably something
something that was floating around out
there but so then that gives us an idea
about how to how to understand his work
and I also did want to say a little bit
about influences so it's natural when
you're reading the Kane things to
compare them compare him to Conan
because you got Robert E Howard writing
these pulp novels right and people like
well you know Wagner must have read
Howard and Wagner said yeah I did
later on I didn't read that that stuff
right away he actually edited some
Howard's stuff later on - yep and oh
yeah no there's this is a different game
this is this is like the biblical okay
yeah although I have very changed you
know sort of back story line so he
actually said in one place that one of
the biggest influences on him was CL
more and the GRL of jory stories which
kind of makes sense if you've read it
forgotten more you know they're they're
they're kind of gothic everything else
it said he was influenced by Wilcock
yeah well no I don't think he was
influenced by Moorcock Lovecraft
definitely saw it mentioned more care
more Michael Moorcock they would have
been I mean contemporaries I don't know
how I mean if we if we if we mean like
he interacted with him I'm sure he did
it
conventions and stuff I'm not sure oh I
know you know I think I know because he
has one Kane story towards towards the
end where Kane encounters Elric mm-hmm
so that could be what they have in mind
but I don't think they're really I mean
they're they're he's writing his stuff
pretty early on Moorcock makes it big in
the 60s I mean so I mean more help would
be a bit older right so he is if he
doesn't make it to the 70s yeah more
[ __ ] would be coming on the scene and
getting big 60 in the late 60s he's an
editor he's got so he's got a lot of
Jews could be the case yeah
oh so it's not any case let's talk about
this this world that that Cain lives in
right so you know you can see it right
here man
crudely drawn but you know good enough
and it's helpful for figuring out where
things are in the stories and you know
it's kind of a typical fantasy map
there's mountains there's an island
country there's a big continent there's
like a wasteland you know all sorts of
things like that
and I don't think that I don't think
that Wagner really did that much world
building in terms of the continents
themselves he like peoples them with
different different types of ethnicities
and and you know they're very much like
things from an ancient world in the
medieval world you know kind of blurred
together so there's city-states there's
empires there's all sorts of things
going on but it is a world of when which
magic exists so there's their sorcery
but not most people don't don't do that
sort of thing it's not like you know
some world building like you know an
extreme would be pure as the Anthony's
and stuff where like everybody's got
magic pretty much as a matter of fact I
think if you don't have magic there they
kick you out right or like the Harry
Potter stuff where everybody's throwing
magic around all the time they're it's
you know it's sorcerers and people don't
usually like them so and there's some
you know there's some demons and things
that you could you could deal with and
sometimes that's a good thing to do and
sometimes that's a terrible thing to do
like there's one one the one scene where
there's this wizard who conjures up a
demon who's going to attack Kane he's
got him stuck in a city and the wizard
has the demon contained within this this
pentagram and Kane comes out and he's
being hunted by all these
guys and he throws a spear and
everyone's like oh don't protect the
wizard make sure the spear doesn't hit
the wizard
it's the pentagram cuz that's right Cain
was anything now the demon gets out and
takes the magician or sorcerer warlock
whatever he was takes him back to
whatever realm he's from you know you
want to make sure you've got all your
proverbial eyes dotted and t's crossed
if you're doing that but now it's also a
world in which human beings are not the
first sentient race so there were these
elder races and so there and he doesn't
really go much into it I think it's sort
of a plot device more than more than
something that he wants to develop so
there is there's all of those things
going on and you can find their
technology or things like that and
there's so there's also advanced
technology in this world including
organic technology bloodstone is about
this giant crystal which was a from a
race of crystalline beings that lived
out the universe and one of them comes
down to earth or whatever this land is
and plants itself there and has a race
of people built around it to try to
build this giant power conductor thing
and it wants to take over like the whole
universe so there's a lot of things
going on there and Cain himself is a
product of some really early early human
times so the story is and you get bits
and pieces of it in different novels
there was an elder god there's also guys
- I should mention so the guides do
different things most of them don't seem
to have much they're not particularly
helpful to humanity you know if they've
got their own agendas and so an elder
god decides to make human beings make
make beings like like himself in some
way and Cain gets gets made and
I actually have a timeline which I can
pass around which I found out a site
somebody somebody took the time to put
together like a whole timeline of all
the stuff going out of the novel so the
first thing that happens is this god
perfects the first man after many
attempts a golden age begins and then
Cain is born Cain rebels against God
kills his brother Abel so this is the
biblical story right is marked by the
God with the in this case it's his eyes
that are the mark people can can tell it
and then the Golden Age ends goddess vs.
mankind across the earth Cain is also
cursed because he he employed he brought
about violence that only the Vaught the
same sort of violence can destroy him he
stuck living forever he can be killed
but as it turns out he's like 300 pounds
mostly muscle and bone very fast very
you know very smart also in a prone to
violence and stuff like this so it's
pretty hard to kill this guy they do a
good job on the novels of getting him
close but you really really have to work
hard at it and he also has the advantage
of living you know throughout a lot of
different ages so that we're gonna come
to that that philosophical theme that
shows up in other things what would you
do with immortality you know I think
that that is one of the things so I'll
show you this I'll send this around I
mean it starts at 0 and it goes all the
way to 1880 1855 in this world where
Cain is a Bandit leader and then there's
there's there's a few stories where he
actually is in our world in the 1970s
and 1980s oh so I should mention too
that one of the other things I
discovered Wagner only wrote about half
of the novels he intended for Cain
then park is again got sick and died he
had a whole bunch of other things lined
up sort of plotted out that he wanted to
do we can talk about those later if
you'd like to but so that's I mean
that's the universe he's living and it
says he says it's not a sword and
sorcery universe and he does have one I
had one other things too about that he
says it's it's labeling the genre with
the cliches swords and sorcery that too
many people see as being heroic
fantasies hackneyed limits you might as
well call it blood or thunder or thud
and blunder even it's like calling all
mystery stories whodunits or cops and
robbers or calling all westerns I like
this horse off breath we're calling all
science fiction space opera to condemn
the entire genre for the cliches of one
trivial aspect of it I find very
irritating I didn't know a lot of
science fiction fans and writers hate
the term sci-fi sword and Sworcery
cannon conjures an image of yarns about
girls and brass bras who are in constant
danger of losing them and mighty
warriors with 18-foot long swords
killing wizards and monsters faster than
thought a sword fight every other page
kill a monster every other chapter
rescue a girl and at the end there is
your sword and Sworcery yarn science
fiction has gone a long long ways past
the old days of space pirates and
bug-eyed monsters even though the most
successful things in science fiction
lately opens space opera star wars for
example science fiction itself as a
genre has become far more literary far
more innovative than standard space
opera fare there's also a lot more to
epic fantasy or heroic fantasy than
sword and sorcery would you call
Tolkien's work sword and sorcery you
could do that you'd have to change the
titles to something like Frodo and the
magic ring blurbs are never very
descriptive and they're always
misleading he says so he's gonna he's
marking about his his genre I think he's
right - that his stuff is definitely not
your standard swords and sword and
sorcery fare even though it's got a lot
of the same
let's call it so the same architect
architecture it's got the same furniture
within the world the furniture has not
arranged the same way there's something
different going on in Carla we're than
there there is even a really good sword
& Sworcery like Fritz Leiber maybe like
the faux fur tin the Great Mouse or
stuff that's the sort of sorcery maybe a
bit better than the average fair but
this is this is this is quite different
so I've been doing a lot of talking do
you guys have any questions or remarks
that you want to make at this point or
no I just think that I run into a lot of
people who are resistant to reading
fantasy and science fiction because of
the label to reading both of them or
either either of them that they don't
like I'm gonna book like they won't they
won't even if it's Malta interesting
because they won't even consider it
wasn't think about it and I tell them
all the time
it's not the bangbang shoot-'em-up in
space yeah that science fiction has is
literary yeah yeah there's a lot of
stuff that is very literary and they
won't touch it
and conversely their communities who
think that science fiction or fantasy
the lowest common denominator
that's what's on screen like Esther over
telling some when I wrote science
fiction and she was like oh like avatar
[Laughter]
Wow
yeah that's setting the bar low what
happened to our had some literary yeah
but I mean it's environmental one yeah
I'm sort of yellow just like through
tropes you know the wonderful you know
savior comes in with the aliens and
learn you know goes through his
character arc of like you know becoming
the good guy and a science fiction story
story it's kind of looked down on is
very simplistic like just running around
bashing isn't it I thought yeah it is
that but it's great I mean and it's all
it is oh yeah I'm very much like the
cohan stuff but just as an example I
mean there are others that you can do so
many things in the genre but I'd look
why do people look down on this is this
is fun I think that's something a lot of
stories you know that I think that the
escapism and fun of it is for like
academic types I think that's that's
something they looked out upon yeah you
know it's that it's not yeah there was a
joke and I think I brought it up a a
number of times back somebody had
somebody who were reading and they they
they were saying something about
academics their idea of a great story is
it's about academics and one of them has
an affair
then they have the other one like
questions their life or something like
that and yeah then and then they're
dense you know but so they they look at
and it's not like sword & Sworcery stuff
is always like everything's tied up with
a neat bow at the end yeah that's that's
quite true oh yeah yeah they're there I
mean when we're talking about Douglas
Adams you're talking about like a
science comedy almost right I think we
could use that as and the Zen things do
that for fantasy although a lot of the
jokes are pretty dated you know appears
Anthony stuff well let's talk about some
of the big themes then so we got a hero
who's immortal right that introduces a
lot of interesting wrinkles it's been
done in a lot of different ways you know
we're gonna look at Bram Stoker later on
obviously you know vampires are immortal
until somebody kills them so they have
the same sort of thing but what do you
do with all this time Philip Jose hope
Philip was a farmer had the world of
Tears series where there were these
people who were practically immortal as
well and they there's so much height
there's so much farther above the rest
of us poor Schmucks that you know just
living a short life time that they they
look at us has not even like slaves you
know they make their own little worlds
and the river world thing too is also
playing around with immortality but you
know you don't get quite so much time in
that this guy has been around literally
through all of human history and it it
kind of weighs on him because he remarks
you know it
one of the stories can't get too
attached to anybody because you fall in
love you get to see them die in about 50
years and you get the idea that he did
it a couple times to begin with all the
Highlanders yeah yeah well if they saw
germane books by she'll see the new
Yarbrough tell me about those series
okay and he was born 6,000 years ago
okay pill and and he regularly the
character or song germane each novel is
a piece of history
yeah so it's very historical fiction -
okay like one is said in the building of
st. Petersburg hmm and what is one is
set during world war two and one is set
in Nero's room okay and one is set so
each novel is set in a piece of history
and she does a really good job of
historical research yeah and she drops
his character in history
that's a really smart way to set things
up if you like to do historical reasons
cos he struggles because he could be
anywhere
you could be anywhere he struggles with
out living the people he loves yeah you
know and the people he comes to be fond
of the humans he has to be fond of and
it's an interesting series I think it's
a really have enjoyed it it's okay I
read it I read every one that you're
good you know yeah I don't feel like I
don't
that was one of his strongest though
Wagner strongest was having that
immortality I wasn't buying it yeah I
only love stuff okay I just wasn't
buying it like that was kind of you know
like you talk about their living so much
that time this should be smarter but I
felt like he's just telling us that I'm
not showing us anything that back that
up yeah especially in the relationship
he had with the girl I can't think of
her name the one who was sort of the
warrior wolf herself yeah
Terrace yeah yeah so you know like at
every turn that's one well in that nah
well that's one where Cain is without
realizing it sort of like seduced by
this this this crystal and has his he's
gonna become the slaves
yeah his reasoning capacities get get
kind of short-circuited right you know I
mean I guess that's somewhat of the
claim but but again it was a to me it
was just if you would live that long
you know why wasn't he smarter or wiser
and I guess what I wasn't buying if
you're immortal yeah what the connection
was to the past and this crystal wasn't
solidified
enough for me that why didn't he know
what it was oh because because the
crystal antedated humankind okay it was
there it was there that whole race of I
forget what they're called the amphibian
kind of creatures they were one of the
earlier races I thought for some reason
there was a race that had been wiped out
almost that brought the crystal that
they then took the crystal from its
brothers oh no no the crystals
themselves were a race out there in the
cosmos right they were separate yeah so
this one comes down and it gets those
frog people to be it's essentially its
slaves you know and it's gonna build
this wonderful power producing thing I
know there's a lot of stuff in here is
kinda you know what do you think about
it it's not gonna hold on but yeah there
and then they start out like the crystal
changes them somehow and and then things
break down and they become degenerate
you know but they're but they're there
before humans
yeah and Keena first thinks the crystal
is going to give him all sorts of power
not realizing it's it's using him to get
the power but the the the the thing with
terrace that's probably the longest
relationship we get to see between Cain
and some sort of romantic partner
there's there's another woman in death
angels shadow who is born blind and has
the power to see like people's souls and
stuff like that and she tries to help
heal people and she's hanging out with
Cain for a while and there's this whole
crowd of like Crusaders that are coming
to kill him and one of them is a decent
guy who came doesn't kill kills
everybody else and she stays to help
heal this this other guy so she leaves
him there's this twisted torn apart
then you know half-demon queen of that
island country Pelin who he's involved
with for a while but it's that's no
don't treat because she's half crazy and
her body is totally attracted and you
know her him being her general a part of
the price is he has to sleep with her
you know
and who else there I think they were
there are a few others where there's
like a hint that something could happen
but then for the most part he's like you
know he'll he'll sleep with with people
but he's like totally unattached because
could it be an element of yeah he's been
around a long time I mean he's learned a
lot of things he's hurt but he's he's
essentially human Williams yeah he's
essentially healer any human mistake
that's one things that in the song
humane novels break your leg is he'll
say to himself I should have known
better you know I know better than that
and he doesn't anyway because there's
there's still this there's a human piece
he's he's human
he's maybe as a vampire but he he was he
started out human maybe there's an
infinite capacity for humans to to screw
things up like you you know you figured
you figure these out yet you still don't
realize you're gonna screw things up
this way he goes down the past sometimes
deliberately knowing it's wrong to do
he's gonna do interesting he's gonna do
it anyway and he should learn better I
think you should know better
yeah and there are those discussions
periodically throughout the books and
it's it's this is that it's a human
instinct thing it's just okay I know I'm
wrong to do this but I'm gonna do it
anyway I mean with Kim and he does have
some friendships to that that last you
know while the person is alive but what
he really throws is his weight into his
when is when he's interested in sorcery
he learns sorcery because we read about
him using spells or learning and having
learned to through this person or that
person but for the most part he's really
interested in like being a general or an
admiral and you know or or being a king
and running things and with that when
you you at a certain point you're
wondering well why you know and maybe
part of the answer is he's so powerful
as a person he's got this massive Bank
of you know memories and knowledge he's
as a physical specimen he's almost
unbeatable unless you've got some sort
of monster because he's he's described
as being like that you know a 300-pound
sort of super built kind of guy who
isn't muscle-bound Karl whatever Ragnar
actually got in an argument with people
who are like no if he was that if he was
that he had muscles that big he wouldn't
be able to move very quickly and he
found a guy who actually had muscles
that big who actually was quite nimble
and then he was like see there you go
King King could exist so he can he can
deal with almost any situation that he
runs into he also heals very quickly you
know so he's kind of like it's sort of
like a you know in superhero stuff you
start like some sort of mutant or you
know superhero and you might say well
why then do all this conquest stuff and
I guess the answer is well because he
can and there's not a hell of a lot else
to do I mean he we already know that he
reads philosophy and studies all this
other stuff and he mentions like
somebody will bring up an idea and yeah
yeah I remember when so and so the
person that you're referring to actually
like gave a lecture on that you know and
people yeah
yeah but he does so he's got to share a
culture but then he's always getting
getting his hands into the sort of the
the bloody arena of politics and now
that politics like electioneering but
you know taking over kingdoms stuff like
that really high death tolls of these
books you know if you think about if
with cane is around there's there's lots
and lots of trouble one of the things
that people some people have brought up
is whether cane is really what we would
call nihilistic that is he doesn't
actually have any sort of moral values
or think that the world contains any
reliable moral values some people said
that about Conan I think there's
probably Cain probably has a better
claim to that than Conan would you know
but maybe that's a factor of living so
long maybe maybe it's it's bad to live
too long you know it's it maybe it takes
away something from our humanity to to
exist too long you know everything
there's two possibilities right if we
can we we often die well we want to
extend our lives through technology and
medicine and all that and it wouldn't be
cool if we could all have like a hundred
and ten year life expectancy instead of
you know 70 something years or what if
we could live forever you know and not
just like upload our consciousness that
the cloud live forever but like in these
bodies what if we could live forever
wouldn't that be great all those those
jobs that you wanted to get to around
the house be able to do that or you know
less trivial stuff you know if you
wanted to learn all these different
languages you would finally have the
time to do it but I don't know what
would most of us be when we reach a
point where like
and it's enough of this makes me think
of it go two ways
yeah you've got the people who when they
retire die of boredom yeah sure if they
have no other interests and then you've
got the people I mean who I probably
would fill every hour and still want do
more you you feel the space and if you
if you have lots of interests and there
are things you want to do there's never
enough time yeah does that classic
episode of the 1990 Highlander Series
where our hero comes across a pianist
lady and discovers that she is like a
Highlander to be also when she dies and
becomes the Highlander she can play the
piano beautifully she realizes oh I've
lost something yeah you even have that
drive yeah yeah you know what if you
were immortal right so it doesn't even
have a cane sort of things look poof you
know suddenly we're all we're all
immortal and then like I for example
I've tried my hand at an art and the
only things that I can do reasonably
well they're oil pastels because they're
really forgiving to somebody who's
terrible at drawing you know I'm never
gonna be able to draw well I can take
drawing classes all I want and I can I
can improve to a certain extent but I'm
never going to be really good or you
know I play the banjo and I play the
bass and presumably I was pretty good
with with the bass and and I could
probably if I like practiced every every
day and had an eternity to do it I can
probably get really good but I would
never get like expert level good now if
if you think about your own things that
way
we probably all have that wouldn't that
actually make immortality yeah Wow not
just frustrating like irritating like
galling like you know sticking in you
know the proverbial like you know thorn
in your side I can't do this
this thing you know and you know you'd
never be able to do it oh yeah yeah you
know the story the starting with Abraham
you think about that guy right just I
mean it's it's it's a crazy story he
gets to talk with God and try to like
bargain about of you know destroying
Sodom and then you know he's I mean
here's there's the one that I had
something I used to teach like Old
Testament classes I try to get the
students to think about what things what
things were actually entailed in these
short verses and so when they have the
Covenant
Abraham is told ok the mark of the
Covenant is circumcision so you're gonna
have to be circumcised and all of your
your you know people under you well he
was like a tribal Sheikh by that time he
had like 600 guys so imagine that
conversation you know now the knives
back that were stone knives - it wasn't
like you know nice surgical steel or so
there's no anesthetic and all that so
imagine like having that conversation
him saying all right so I did this thing
I talked with God and
yeah now I I went through it myself you
didn't see me last week because I was
laid up for a while make a line it's
gonna be a long day I mean there's three
after story after story like that you
know and yeah you're like oh that's not
an easy not an easy restful time yeah
exactly
well mortality issues well you mentioned
about Highlander you know some people
are driven by I only have so much time
yeah to get good yeah I only have so
much time to get into my mark if you
don't have that to drive you if you
could if you can fit forever well I'll
do that 10 years from when you see a
lifetime I have time you could oscillate
though because if you think about what
you would when you would waste your time
on there's like basically two main
routes one would be like I'm going to
have as much fun as possible just
indulge myself and pleasures and stuff
like that but after a while that gets
boring alright so then then you're like
maybe I should go develop you know my
sword play or musical talents or
something like that and then you can
also have like that I'm not going to do
anything I'm just going to lay on the
beach and I'm gonna watch netflix all
day long or something like that but that
gets boring too
you know the same dilemma grantee with
the rock the robot stories as most robot
stories where robots do everything oh
yeah yeah what are humans motivated so
that the problem of what they call the
post scarcity future right where yeah
where everything's provided for you if
everything is taken care of
yeah then what okay but then
why for those that believe in
Christianity and believe in an immortal
soul is this like we don't dabble into
that conversation ever or live like that
because they literally have no idea you
know what would you do with all that
time what are you gonna do if you
believe in immortality well there are no
and we don't know what that looks like
and maybe we don't want there's there's
there's thinkers who do like go into it
I mean there's there's this is something
that I bring up in my philosophy classes
when I get to like medieval philosophy
because you know we'll talk about like
you know we'll Rita Augustine or and
some they'll talk about heaven and then
I'll say so you know think about what
heaven would actually be like do you is
that something that you would want and
usually the kids have something that's
very cartoonish you know so what would a
seven like and they say well you know
those angels you're playing a harp and
dressed in white robes and there's
clouds everywhere and you know when I
think about that either
well that sounds super boring why the
hell would I want that
you know and then you know hell is like
getting poked a lot and fire and that
sounds boring to after a while and you
you know you look at somebody like so
the scene handsome in the end of his
press load you know when he's describing
what Heaven's gonna be like he doesn't
go to like any sort of like and then
there's gonna be something over here and
something over here he says first of all
you're gonna be reunited with all the
people who you you love provided they
made it in and that's gonna be a great
good and all of us are going to have the
same the same will not not by like
something supervening on us and making
us into a bunch of like The Body
Snatchers people you know but rather
what what is unique to us would all be
harmonized in some way and so now think
about you know he doesn't go into great
detail but think about what it's like
when you get to know a person before you
screw things up in a relation
you know and you're getting your in that
stage where you're finding out stuff
about them you know that's cool that's I
like that you know
now imagine getting to do that for all
eternity with all these these people and
there's never that moment where you're
like oh that's gross or oh now I know I
don't want to spend any time with that
person instead somehow all the even even
the crappy stuff somehow it gets
recuperated you know that's more
attractive and that that's something
that we could actually like you could
say well I could did I could do that for
eternity one of the other images there's
actually a beautiful icon of it in the
Notre Dame Snite I think it's called art
gallery and it shows the Liturgy of
heaven and the liturgy is supposed to be
this like endless song that's taking
place and you you know there's so
there's this angels down here singing
and then there's higher angels singing
and stuff like that and you know that
also sounds a bit boring but if you
think about like the best time that
you've ever been if you've done music
with people like when you were when you
were in the moment and you were jamming
with them or you were singing some sort
of choral arrangement and everything
came together right and and it almost
like it feels like the whole world is
right at that point right now imagine
doing that for all eternity except the
song is ever-shifting and encompasses
the entire universe and the you know so
they were thinking about that in
medieval times somebody else who thought
about that was Tolkien he has the
Similan is literally the world is song
into existence but but somebody else
thought about that to clement of
alexandria back in the third century AD
i think says that the way in which we
are the way in which were made in the
divine images that were musical so
there's there's you know if you get away
from like the cartoonish notions that I
think people have of what
having would be like these very
superficial ideas then heaven actually
sounds like it could be good you know
anymore
immortality could be something we could
stand so he kind of talks about peeling
layers back of reality where our world
seems like a shadow yeah every major
religion of the world has some concept
of in mortal existence but some of them
afterlife everybody has some even yeah
even Hinduism where their people are
reborn yeah there is some sense of
immortality but some you definitely
wouldn't want like you wouldn't want to
be you know one of the people punished
in Greek Hades like Tantalus you know
trying to reach for the the fruit for
all eternity and having it pulling away
after why I'd be like you know you know
you're still doing it being like this
freaking tree you know there's the
stupid gods you know this is just kill
me now actually the other thing I was
talking about with my my classes earlier
we read Plato's apology and in it
Socrates after he's condemned to death
is consoling his friends by saying it's
a bad argument he says well either
either death is you know like a total
cessation of consciousness or it's going
to a different place and what's bad
about it was he he he conflates total
cessation of consciousness with like the
best night's sleep you've ever had
because you're not you know if it's a
total cessation there's no waking up so
you have no frame of reference but he
does say you know if it's like what they
tell us about Hades that's that's gonna
be great because I'm gonna go down there
and all the the people I've heard about
in history are down there and I'm gonna
get to ask them
questions and find out whether they
really measure up to the stories about
them or not and you won't be able to
kill me down there you can't shut me up
you know I I can go to Achilles and ask
you know did you really do this or that
like that see a picture of this guy
Socrates gone down there and making the
the afterlife worse yeah but he is some
of them I don't think we'd really want
you know I mean actually Anselm said
something else that was quite
interesting that really bothered his
fellow monks he said I wouldn't want to
go to heaven with any stain of sin and I
wouldn't if you know if I were actually
how did he put it you know if I didn't
belong in hell but I got put in hell
anyway how it wouldn't be that bad and
everyone's like wait a second having as
good and hell's bad what the hell are
you talking about he said well I mean if
I was in heaven and I didn't deserve to
be in a band it would be a bad place for
me I'd feel like you know getting guilty
and always be like looking over my
shoulder I don't know I only watch like
that a couple episodes yeah she is she's
in there by mistake right yeah but but
he says you know if I didn't deserve to
be in hell Halliwell actually wouldn't
be that bad gonna poke you a bit but you
wouldn't you wouldn't you wouldn't have
this sense that you belong there you
know and then when he explained it the
monks were like oh yeah okay
that makes sense with King we don't have
anything like that it's just an immoral
guy who wanders around it's really kind
of interesting too that this guy Wagner
who dies so young he was clearly not
immortal all right he dies of something
that in some respect is probably imposed
upon himself through his way of living
he's got this character that he begins
with quite young and he
churns this stuff through it's his most
important character and so he's almost
you can't say he's an alter ego or just
wish fulfillment or something like that
there's something else going on there
too maybe you know they've got this very
mortal vessel for a immortal thought the
other thing that I wanted to bring up
was Oh
so yeah this uh I didn't team go bad all
right you got a God who makes human
beings and like you know the biblical
story we don't know at all we just have
there's two brothers and one of them is
angry because God likes the the other
guys sacrificed better and God cautions
them and says you know I can see that
you know he says first of all why is
your face falling and why are you angry
and came you know doesn't want to speak
and he says sin is you know waiting for
you like a dog at the door if I remember
right don't let it don't let it get you
so obviously Cain had some sort of
choice there in the Genesis story and
then Cain kills Abel then tries to you
know tell God I don't know where he is
I'm not I'm just keep her and then God
curses him and sends and sends him out
right and in the Genesis story it
doesn't really make sense to say that
they're the only people on earth because
obviously how did Cain become like the
father in many cities or anything like
that yeah
affection well the sign of Kenan these
boxes his eyes all right
Oh
Wagner always talks about it as people
look at him and what they see in his
eyes is this murderous 'no scares them
even sometimes like you know really
hardened people
no it helps that he's a big badass too
you know I mean if they saw like some
some tiny little you know wait I just
looking at him real intently maybe they
wouldn't be so scared but in Genesis
it's meant to be a sign that God has put
his protection on Cain yeah yeah in this
Mencia had came if the only way he can
die is if somebody does impose the same
violence on on him or if he gets himself
killed I suppose if he takes on too big
of a monster at some point but so the
the elder God who makes humanity there's
an expression like the other God regrets
having done it because of because of
Cain and you can say well how does how
does this go wrong is it just like you
know they're too raw they can't control
their emotions they haven't like evolved
enough or become civilized enough or is
it maybe that there's there's maybe the
we look at in a sort of bigger picture
thing we are a murderous species you
know the closest thing we're to as
chimps and chimps are murderous species
to you know they they're they're one of
the few animals which will actually like
strategically hunt down and kill other
bands of the same species chimps will do
that too
there may be dolphins do that they're
pretty mean too we found out little
minutes to learn so much but by
observing animal behavior you know it's
really quite quite fascinating to find
out how close they are to us in many
respects there's something about being
the rational animal which is the
philosophical definition for the human
being very often we present this as if
it's well where you know there's
animality and then rationality elevates
us makes it makes us so much better
aristotle already saw way back in
ancient greece that it's not that simple
you know he says that the corruption of
the best produces the worst so there's
some you know our rationality allows us
to have a greater sway of destruction
than that the other animals and you know
you can think about this in terms of if
again if we use aristotle his
understanding of anger anger is a
response that the animals have in greek
it's through moster or gay and animals
have them they don't have it like we do
precisely because as rational animals
that communicate with each other we are
concerned with social status in a way
that animals aren't and we're concerned
with conceptions of justice in ways that
animals totally aren't and that allows
us to become angry in ways that animals
don't don't do for the most part maybe
if we civilize them enough you know like
Planet of the Apes maybe making the Apes
more human actually makes them worse you
know and so keen is the the first big
mistake in this this mythology you know
he's the first one that goes bad and how
does he go bad
maybe it's precisely because he realizes
something within humanity that's that's
in all of us as a possibility you know
this being rational being the rational
animal doesn't always mean being a
wonderful animal rationality can be a
kind of a curse there's in in the Thomas
coven oh yeah I haven't thought about
those for a long time I was okay in the
coveted chronicles Lord fouled the
supposed to sort of like the double
figure right yeah angel yeah yeah he
says at the end of the herd book that
Chronicle that covenant will become a
despiser also they call in the third
thousand despiser
yes right he says and it's rationality
the longer you write you're around these
people the longer you live the more you
will just the more you will despise
their father
that's interest they're their faults and
their shortcomings in there you'll see
all this around you in you will despise
it also yeah and come and despise you'll
hate them right you'll start yeah or at
least you won't have any patience for
them yeah and it has to do with the
longer you're around and apply your
rationality yeah what you're seeing the
more you will curdle so if the
rationality is kind of a corrosive
effect yeah being rational and seeing
these people's shortcomings and ya know
failures and what heavy however this is
a little off topic how how was the
series reading through it again does it
hold up yeah well one thing that struck
me is it's far more literary than what
you see today okay
far you need a you need a thesaurus I
haven't around I've been right Donaldson
since like College it is $25 words okay
next year yeah I think that that would
actually be a good idea uh what struck
me was his writing is far more literary
okay then what you see in current
fantasy science fiction right well you
read a lot more contemporary stuff so
what is current science and well
language is more common denominator
level do you think that's in like an
order to sell more books er yeah okay
but it's it's just more like most people
talk with a lot of scifi writers come
from a technical background maybe they
studied science in school okay and they
didn't but that's one thing what struck
me when I was when I went back but the
first book is like oh this is literary
this is and it's very good
world-building yeah but it is you truly
if you don't hey good if you don't have
a good vocabulary yes you get a sorry
silly dictionary I think I remember them
as being hard to read emotionally like
it was hard for me to read through them
because like you there were like so many
places was like getting a gut punch all
the time yeah well he's not
he said yeah he's an antihero yeah I
mean he's not your typical he's not a
hero
yeah he's a hero but very very flawed I
mean when you open the series of the
rape you know sort of standard for some
in the first sentence in the first is
really yeah violence against women
you takin oh wow Hartman started some of
that because everyone wants to be the
next game of Thrones and you get gritty
isn't living the extreme violence huh
yeah I suppose
okay but I think it's a crossover with
the horror genre yeah minor Scott
Baker's gonna have some of that
I haven't haven't gotten around to
reading in Vietnam it's all so busy so
beautiful and Bishop has said her first
book and then that type of violence
diminishes a little bit why well it it
was different yeah change ambition I
found her uncomfortably violent in a
weird she's violent it's and but her
fourth and fifth books are not very
violent okay the first three is because
all of the characters are engaging in
the violence I've been killed off no son
the heroes I find the heroes okay
the heroes are anti-heroes I mean you
have a character who's immortal whose
name is the sadist oh wow and seitan is
major heroes so yeah scared that like
who actually loved I love that character
she does a weird flippy between
extremely domestic comedy yes something
is hilarious arc [ __ ] hmm and she'll
flip like within a couple of pages yeah
which makes it really interesting to
read and kind of just
yeah yeah it's really interesting to
read it so let's bring it back for the
hood okay so notice this notion of the
anti arrows is he an antihero I kind of
feel like it doesn't fit that well to
call him an antihero but I don't want to
say he's not a hero at all because he's
clearly a protagonist right and he's
he's like heroic stature maybe a flawed
hero yeah I mean he doesn't have he
doesn't have like a moral backbone where
where there's something he stands for
maybe isn't it maybe maybe the problem
is how we define hero hmm
okay how so well I think you know do you
find hero in a Marvel Comics kind of way
yeah or is here a more complex than that
yeah I think growing up as children we
see Superman and you know the heroes who
are had these moral compasses like the
squeaky clean ones cleaning I mean back
then they'd be like that man he's dark
and twisted he always does the right
thing he always does the right thing at
least in the early yeah literally stuff
he always does the right thing yeah that
your flash and Green Lantern
yeah flash is pretty clean there's
really squeaky clean
Captain America that whole crowd really
pretty squeaky clean and if you define
hero in that way yeah then he's not here
oh yeah definitely I mean I think maybe
now that I think about it maybe part of
why I want to call him an antihero as
I've seen the term used so much of other
types of characters that it just doesn't
and it doesn't feel like it works for
for for him
but he's definitely not a good guy you
know he's also not contemptuous of
goodness though maybe then maybe that's
the only thing that's really redeeming
about Cain slowly like you mentioned a
somewhat moral character he's not an
immortal sadist and he's not he's not
totally divorced from humanity where
these think I'm above it you know you
can't relate to it at all if somebody's
nice to him he's nice to them too you
know but he'll also kill them if they
get in the way unless he takes a shine
to him and the only thing keeping them
safe is that he's taking a shine to them
temporarily I don't know that there's
anything really admirable about Cain
though you could you know you could you
could like think he's cool or something
like that but I don't think anyone say I
want to be Cain there's no emulation
capacity there at least not for somebody
who's you know well-adjusted probably
relatively I don't know there's a lot
there's a lot for me to to think about
do you have any other philosophical
themes you wanted to bring up or ideas
or stuff from though they're gonna start
kicking us out pretty soon no maybe the
thing with Cain is it's a hero heroism
is complex yeah there are complexities
there's it's not simplistic so it's more
like a historical work and in some ways
right we're like good good history
doesn't make Abraham Lincoln the the you
know the wonderful guy who never did
anything wrong or something
yeah Thomas Jefferson yeah worried where
a guy who wasn't very good at winning
battles he was really good at getting
himself appointed to post and other
people not appointed to posts like
Benedict Arnold you know who probably
was a better general but you know
definitely a guy over the fatal flaw
all right well let's let's bring it to a
close it's thanks for all the questions
and comments and conversation I really
enjoyed going back and reading Keene
again that came Wagner so so next time
is Alice Huxley we're looking at utopian
and anti utopian stuff so of course
brave new world but also the island
[Music]
you